Bueno, es fantástico estar aquí.
Hemos escuchado mucho sobre la promesa de la tecnología, y el riesgo.
He estado bastante interesado en ambos.
Si pudiéramos convertir el 0,03 por ciento
de la luz solar que cae sobre la tierra en energía,
podríamos satisfacer todas nuestras necesidades proyectadas para 2030.
No podemos hacer esto hoy porque los paneles solares son pesados,
caros y muy ineficientes.
Existen diseños de nano-ingeniería,
los cuales han sido analizados al menos teóricamente,
que muestran el potencial de ser muy livianos,
muy baratos, muy eficientes,
y podríamos satisfacer todas nuestras necesidades de energía de esta forma renovable.
Células combustibles de nano-ingeniería
podrían proveer la energía donde se necesite.
Esa es la tendencia principal, la descentralización,
ir de plantas nucleares de energía centralizadas y
cisternas de gas natural líquido
hacia recursos descentralizados que son más amigables ecológicamente,
mucho más eficientes,
y capaces y seguros con respecto a la disrupción.
Bono habló muy elocuentemente,
sobre que tenemos las herramientas, por primera vez,
para solucionar los viejos problemas de las enfermedades y la pobreza.
La mayor parte de las regiones del mundo van en esa dirección.
En 1990, en Asia del Este y la región del Pacífico,
había 500 millones de personas viviendo en la pobreza --
ese número hoy está bajo los 200 millones.
El Banco Mundial tiene previsto para 2011 que esté por debajo de los 20 millones,
lo cual es una reducción del 95 por ciento.
Me gustó el comentario de Bono
relacionando Haight-Ashbury con Silicon Valley.
Viniendo yo de la communidad de alta tecnología de Massachusetts,
remarcaría que éramos hippies también en los 60,
a pesar de que nos juntábamos por Harvard Square.
Pero tenemos el potencial de solucionar la enfermedad y la pobreza,
y voy a hablar de esos temas, si tenemos ganas.
Kevin Kelly habló de la aceleración de la tecnología.
Esto ha sido de fuerte interés para mí,
y un tema que he desarrollado durante casi 30 años.
Me di cuenta de que mis tecnologías debían tener sentido para cuando finalizara el proyecto.
Que, invariablemente, el mundo sería un lugar diferente
para cuando introdujera una tecnología.
Y me di cuenta de que la mayoría de los inventos fallan,
no porque el departamento de I+T no pueda hacerlo funcionar --
Si vieran la mayoría de los planes de negocios, la mayoría tendría éxito
si tuvieran la oportunidad de construir aquello que dicen que construirían,
y el 90 por ciento de estos proyectos o más fracasaría por ser el momento equivocado --
no todos los factores que permitan el éxito estarán en su lugar cuando se necesiten.
Por lo cual, comencé a ser un estudiante ardiente de las tendencias de la tecnología,
y a rastrear dónde la tecnología estaría en diferentes puntos en el tiempo,
y comencé a construir modelos matemáticos de ello.
Tomó vida propia, de alguna manera,
Tengo un grupo de 10 personas que trabajan conmigo para recabar información
sobre mediciones clave de la tecnología en diferentes áreas, y construimos modelos.
Y escucharán a la gente decír, bueno, no podemos predecir el futuro.
Y si me preguntan,
¿subirá o bajará el precio de Google de aquí a tres años?
Eso es muy difícil de decir.
¿Será WiMax CDMA G3
el estándar wireless de aquí a tres años? Eso es difícil de decir.
Pero si me preguntan, cuánto costará
un MIPS de cómputo en 2010,
o el costo de secuenciar un par de bases de ADN en 2012,
o el costo de enviar un megabyte de datos por wireless en 2014,
resulta que estos son muy predecibles.
Hay curvas exponenciales remarcadamente suaves
que gobiernan el precio del comportamiento, capacidad, ancho de banda.
Y voy a mostrarles una pequeña muestra de esto,
aunque existe realmente una razón teórica
de por qué la tecnología se desarrolla de manera exponencial.
Y mucha gente, cuando piensa en el futuro, lo piensa de manera lineal.
Piensan que continuarán
desarrollando un problema
o solucionando un problema usando las herramientas actuales,
a la velocidad actual de progreso,
y fracasan en tomar en consideración este crecimiento exponencial.
El proyecto del genoma era un proyecto controvertido en 1990.
Pusimos a nuestros mejores estudiantes de medicina,
nuestros más avanzados equipos del mundo,
logramos realizar 1/10.000 del proyecto,
¿entonces cómo íbamos a realizar esto en 15 años?
Y tras 10 años de proyecto,
los escépticos eran todavía fuertes -- decían "Llegaron a dos tercios de este proyecto,
y han llegado sólo ha secuenciar
un porcentaje muy pequeño del genoma completo".
Pero es la naturaleza del crecimiento exponencial
que una vez que llega a la inflexión de la curva, explota.
La mayor parte del proyecto fue realizado en los últimos
pocos años del proyecto.
Nos llevó 15 años secuenciar el VIH --
secuenciamos el SARS en 31 días.
Por lo que estamos ganando el potencial para solucionar estos problemas.
Voy a mostrarles unos pocos ejemplos
de cuán penetrante es este fenómeno.
El índice actual de cambio de paradigma, el índice de adopción de nuevas ideas,
se está duplicando cada década, de acuerdo con nuestros modelos.
Estos son todos gráficos logarítmicos,
así que a medida que vas subiendo el nivel que representa, generalmente multiplicando por un factor de 10 o 100.
Nos llevó casi medio siglo adoptar el teléfono,
la primera tecnología de realidad virtual.
Los teléfonos móviles se adoptaron en casi 8 años.
Si pusiéramos diferentes tecnologías de comunicación
en este gráfico logarítmico,
televisión, radio, teléfono
fueron adoptados en décadas.
Tecnologías recientes --como el PC, la Web, télefonos móviles--
se adoptaron en menos de una década.
Ahora, éste es un gráfico interesante,
y muestra realmente la razón fundamental por la que
un proceso evolutivo --y la biología y tecnología lo son--
se aceleran.
Trabajan a través de la interacción --crean una capacidad,
y luego utilizan esa capacidad para dar el próximo paso.
Entonces el primer paso en la evolución biológica,
la evolución del ADN --a decir verdad el ARN fue primero--
necesitó billones de años,
pero entonces la evolución utilizó ese pilar de procesamiento de la información
para dar lugar al siguente nivel.
Así, la Explosión Cámbrica, donde todos los planos corpóreos de los animales evolucionaron,
llevó sólo 10 millones de años. Fue 200 veces más rápida.
Y entonces la evolución utilizó esos planos corpóreos
para evolucionar en funciones cognitivas más elevadas,
y la evolución biológica continuó acelerando.
Es la naturaleza inherente a los procesos evolutivos.
Entonces, el Homo Sapiens, la primera especie creadora de tecnología,
la especie que combinó una función cognitiva
con un apéndice oponible (el pulgar)
--y dicho sea de paso, los chimpancés no tienen realmente un buen pulgar--
para que que pudiéramos manipular nuestro ambiente con un agarre potente
y una buena coordinación motora,
y usar nuestros modelos mentales para cambiar efectivamente el mundo
y dar lugar a la tecnología.
Pero, de todas formas, la evolución de nuestras especies tomó cientos de miles de años,
y luego trabajando a través de la interacción,
la evolución usó, esencialmente,
la tecnología de crear especies para dar lugar al próximo nivel,
que fueron los primeros pasos de la evolución tecnológica.
Y los primeros pasos tomaron decenas de miles de años
--herramientas de piedra, fuego, la rueda-- continuaron acelerando.
Siempre usamos, entonces, la última generación de tecnología
para crear la próxima generación.
La imprenta llevó un siglo en ser adoptada,
las primeras computadoras fueron diseñadas con papel y lápiz --ahora usamos computadoras.
Y hemos tenido una continua aceleración de este proceso.
Dicho sea de paso, si miran este gráfico lineal, parece que todo acaba de suceder,
pero un observador dice: "Bueno, Kurzweil sólo marca puntos en este gráfico
que caen sobre esa línea recta".
Así que tomé 15 listas diferentes de pensadores clave,
como la Enciclopedia Británica, el Museo de Historia Natural, el Calendario Cósmico de Carl Sagan
sobre el mismo-- y esta gente no estaba tratando de convercerlos de mi punto de vista,
éstas fueron listas en trabajos de referencia.
Y creo que que esto es lo que ellos consideraron eventos clave
en la evolución biológica y tecnológica.
Y, de nuevo, forma la misma línea recta. Hay un poco de grosor en la línea
porque la gente tiene de hecho desacuerdos sobre cuáles son los puntos clave,
hay diferencias de opinión sobre cuándo comenzó la agricultura,
o cuándo -- cuánto tiempo duró la Explosión Cámbrica.
Pero pueden ver una muy clara tendencia.
Hay una básica, profunda aceleración de este proceso evolutivo.
Las tecnologías de la información duplican su capacidad, calidad/precio, ancho de banda,
cada año.
Y esa es una explosión profunda del crecimiento exponencial.
Una experiencia personal, cuando estaba en el MIT
una computadora ocupaba casi el tamaño de este recinto,
y era menos poderosa que la de sus teléfonos móviles.
Pero la Ley de Moore, usualmente identificada con este crecimiento exponencial,
es sólo un ejemplo de muchos, porque es básicamente
una característica del proceso evolutivo de la tecnología.
Si nosotros -- yo pongo 49 computadoras famosas en este gráfico logarítmico
--dicho sea de paso, una línea recta en un gráfico logarítmico es crecimiento exponencial--
esto es otro exponencial.
nos llevó 3 años doblar nuestro relación calidad/precio de la computación en 1900,